FEDERICO BONGIOVANNI:
Hello, everybody.
My name is Federico Bongiovanni.
I am an engineer and
manager here at Google.
I work in Google Cloud, and
specifically in Kubernetes.
I just finished my talk, which
was about an introduction
to SIG API Machinery.
I am the co-chair of
the SIG API Machinery,
which is a central part
of Kubernetes clusters.
As you know, all your
requests, anything that you
want to do with the
cluster is going
to come through our software.
What are the parts of one
of Kubernetes that we own
and also what are the parts of
Kubernetes that we don't own?
Some people think
that because we
are called API Machinery we own
all the Kubernetes APIs, which
is not the right thing.
So yeah, I think was
a good talk to give
an overview of what we own.
The other part of the talk was
about how you can get involved,
if you want, into
open-source community,
and specifically in Kubernetes.
API Machinery has
this fame of being
a super hard part of the
Kubernetes cluster, which
is true.
We have a big responsibility,
but it's not impossible.
So I would love to see
some of you showing up
in our open-source meetings.
So come, show up, learn,
listen, contribute, help us.
I would also like
to invite all of you
to come to the
Google booths here.
It's looking very good.
So thank you very much.
And see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]